Can somebody please tell me why
healthcare in America is so darn expensive
okay this is also a friendly reminder to be careful with new knives
because I was washing them
I was scrubbing them and it slipped for my little girl grip doesn't matter
I sliced my arm open
had to go to urgent care
the ER and apparently it cost like 700 something dollars
so that's great
and that was a week ago
they glued me shut
they didn't even stitch me
which I'm pretty sure I needed stitches
it was that bad
and then today
I’m getting ready to go to the gym
and the glue just falls off
I'm gonna spare you the disgusting details
but it opened okay
so I go back to urgent care today Sunday
to see if they can patch me up
fix me up and they're like yeah no
we can't close wounds after like 24 hours of injury
It’s been a week
so I'm left to just kind of figure it out
they said it should just heal and scab
so now I'm gonna be left with a giant scar
not only that
they're like you could use sterile strips to close it
and I had to do that myself
yeah so now I have this
I didn't have Scissors to cut the tape
but why is healthcare so expensive
please tell me why, please
Anyways I just had to get that off my chest
I just finished working out
so I guess I'm also curious
do you have a health related injury or accident that happened
that you're just like
why am I now in debt
I'm curious if you have injured yourself
um okay
I have to go the ACS is off so you can hear me so bye